i shared some fun facts about sarah
before the break and now it's time to
reveal which one are drew
and which one are false in our game we
call true or false
okay let's see the facts again a sarah
has a tattoo of the infamous connor's
couch b
sarah has three cats all named tony um
or c sarah's first girl kiss
was with little old me
okay sarah which one is true all right
the
true one is c my first
girl kiss was with drew
and now i'm not one to kiss and tell but
please but i have to say
look now i'm like in a blush true i was
the coolest
person that i ever met and yeah
and that's what happened well we were
supposed to um
kiss on in the movie but then we started
practicing in the trailer which was kind
of fun
we had to practice right it was really
just us doing research
exactly we were like oh i guess we
should like practice
because we want it to look good on
screen
we had so much fun i remember i feel
like it was in the parking lot in los
feliz
right we were like had that little base
camp
oh yeah i drove that jeep and i used to
go get like ice cream on the lunch
breaks and
i was like constantly getting into
accidents i think i got my license taken
away on that movie
i remember you like dancing on the hood
of the jeep
and yeah it was you were a wild child
but in the best possible way
i was impressed
i am still so impressed with you
in fact i was like oh like i mean
i loved and watched you on the talk for
so many years i was curious of like any
words of wisdom you know
like any thoughts for me and my new job
oh you're doing such an amazing job i
mean i think
it's a perfect job for you because the
people who do the best at it
aren't authentic and you are so you
you couldn't really be any other way
and you're so human and caring and it's
just
ideal are you are you loving it
i really i love it a lot i love it so
much
yeah and are you able to find time to
act and do other things you love or has
it been
um no it's it's the kids
you know the kids are on the front
burner and
in fact i stopped doing movies for a
while because i
i wanted to raise them and and be a
present mom
and then the further i got away from
that the more i had a harder time
connecting with it
and i thought i've got to find the
pretty little middle i i want to work
and i want to be there for my kids and
then this job is as hard as it is it's
good for
for both and you know how do you
like try to balance it all with
everything you're doing and your kids
um i think i just take it day to day and
look at where there's time and try to
make sure that
you know when five or five o'clock or
dinner comes that
no matter how busy the day is there's
that connecting time
towards the end of the day but it's it's
for sure
always a balance and some days are
better than others
and like carly to bring it full circle
you know think outside of yourself as
much as we're all
drowning within and around that the 17
year old is out there
taking care of helpless creatures and
what an inspiration for us as humans as
parents
and everything else yeah and it does
make you feel
so much better when you're able to give
and give back
and do for others you know it does
a lot for your own mental well-being
yeah and seeing people do good things
sarah
i you are just the best
girl kiss a girl could ever ask for and
i miss
you dearly me too same on all
of the above the connors airs wednesday
on
abc
[Music]
you